autre grand entretien nous recevons ce
soir l'économiste julia cagé elle vient
de publier un livre sur l'économie des
médias et sur la nuisance des
actionnaires et des grands propriétaires
qui interfèrent dans les contenus ça
s'appelle l'information est un bien
public et son objectif est notamment
d'interpeller les futurs candidats à la
présidentielle julia cagé s'est par
exemple engagé dans le dossier science
et vie le magazine a été racheté ses
salariés considèrent que l'actionnaire a
vidé le contenu de sa substance beaucoup
ont claqué la porte on en parle avec
notre invité juste après le reportage de
fabien becker
quand hervé poirier feuillette un numéro
de science et vie c'est avec des
sentiments contradictoires
un peu d'amertume un peu de tristesse et
beaucoup de
très bon souvenir ce journaliste
scientifique a travaillé 21 ans la
science et vie jusqu'à en devenir le
directeur de la rédaction
avant de claquer la porte en désaccord
avec le nouvel actionnaire et world
hervé ne reconnaît plus son ancien
journal l'exemple le plus frappant dans
le numéro daté avril et semble se publie
communiqué où le principal producteur
d'anti-inflammatoires fait un plat jihad
article en s'appuyant sur des
scientifiques qu'il a lui-même payé pour
dire tout le bien qu'il y aurait à
consommer de plus en plus d'anti
inflammatoires donc cette page là est
clairement à mon époque quand j'étais
directeur de la rédaction n'aurait pas
pu passer comme ça hervé poirier avait
pourtant cru en ce nouvel actionnaire
spécialiste de la transition numérique
mais deux décisions successives de sa
hiérarchie l'ont fait déchanter
brutalement ils m'ont annoncé que la
rédaction sur saisie perdait le contrôle
de la production éditoriale du site
chose qui était inacceptable pour pour
moi c'est à dire que c'était plus la
rédaction qui allait produire des
informations sur le site c'est la cité
de sciences éviter la vitrine de
l'ensemble de cette marque de presse
deuxième point c'était les moyens il
aurait nié les moyens qu'il s'était
engagé à donner or faire un magazine
scientifique racontait des histoires
émouvantes pétri par le réel pétri par
la rencontre avec 150 chercheurs par
chaque mois et c'était ce défi-là
interrogé 150 chercheurs
donc il fallait des moyens et ses moyens
n'étaient plus une disposition il est
coupé au départ d'hervé poirier a
succédé celui de la directrice adjointe
de la rédaction
après des semaines de lutte se sont
finalement neuf autres journalistes qui
démissionnent collectivement si le
journal continue malgré tout d'être
fabriqués par des journalistes
professionnels
ce n'est plus le cas du site internet de
sciences et vie
en salaire comme des journalistes à la
pige puis-je à l'arrière on les paye
comme auto-entrepreneur prestataire de
service ni à peut-être quelques-uns
gauche comme chargé de contenu web
responsable d'audience mais tout ça
c'est une logique d'audience orienté
vers la publicité
et ce n'est pas du tout une logique
d'information grazia science et vie auto
plus autant de titres rachetés par world
au groupe mondadori qui verraient leurs
rédactions menacé selon ce syndicaliste
comme toutes les entreprises de presse
reward bénéficie pourtant d'une aide
indirecte de l'état vis à des tarifs
postaux préférentiels pour livrer ses
abonnés ou un taux de tva super réduit
de quoi inciter le gouvernement à
repenser le système des aides comme le
préconise le sénateur michel laugier
rapporteur pour la presse lors de
l'examen du budget au sénat
puisqu'on parle de presse d'information
quand on parle des informations pour moi
y'a journalistes
et quand il ya journalistes il y a aussi
une vieille anthologie dont c'est pour
ça que il faut que les choses se soient
aujourd'hui
larry fier par exemple en fixant une
part minimum de la masse salariale dédié
à la rémunération de journalistes reward
médias n'a pas répondu à nos questions
le groupe a réalisé l'an dernier plus de
400 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires allons plus loin donc dans
cet entretien avec julia cagé bienvenue
à vous vous êtes économiste profession
ce pot et vous publiez avec l'avocat
benoît huet l'information est un bien
public
on vient de voir le cas de sciences et
vie que vous connaissez bien est ce que
pour vous il est révélateur d'une
tendance inquiétante plus générale dans
les médias français
oui est il révélateur d'une d'une double
tendance inquiétante la première c'est
de produire de l'information qui n'en
est plus puisque l'idée c'est de
produire de l'information sans
journalistes que reward a vraiment
poussé au bout de la logique en
remplaçant les journalistes et en
l'assumant d'ailleurs parce qu'ils
appellent des managers de de contenu
donc l'idée c'est finalement d'aller
faire du copier-coller d'autres contenus
copier en ligne et d'abandonner toute
idée d' informations reward ça ça pousse
vraiment ça à l'extrême mais l'autre
tendance vraiment inquiétante c'est la
tendance à l'externalisation et
notamment à l'externalisation de tout un
ensemble de fonctions alors qu'on
voudrait nous présenter comme des
fonctions support mais qui sont en fait
des fonctions indispensables notamment
pour le fait de faire un journal que ce
soit sur un site internet ont un journal
papier
on l'a vu récemment par exemple aux
inrocks mais il ya plein d'autres
exemples dans l'actualité récente où
vous allez prendre les maquettistes
prendre ceux qui sont chargés de faire
la correction la mise en forme et vous
allez externaliser ses fonctions il nous
gardait finalement qu'une masse
salariale extrêmement réduite pourquoi
pour réduire les coûts donc c'est une
tendance à faire de l'information low
cost le problème c'est que c'est
finalement rentable sur le court terme
pour les actionnaires puisque en fait
ils vont gagner sur le court terme
autant d'argent en dépensant beaucoup
moins mais ça un coup immense 1 pour les
journalistes
faut quand même pas c'est tous les
salariés des médias parce que c'est un
immense en gâchis de talents puis
surtout pour nous citoyens parce que de
ce fait on est beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins formés essais et c'est pour ça
qu'avec avec benoît sûrs on voulait
écrire ce livre pour poser un certain
nombre de principes parce que ce qui
nous semble urgent et nécessaire c'est
que le régulateur en fait interviennent
ici pour rappeler un certain nombre
d'évidences et je pense que la première
de ces évidences ce qu'on peut pas faire
d'informations sur journalistes on
viendra peut-être aux solutions dans un
instant d'abord cette information qu'on
a apprise dans l'après midi l'autorité
de la concurrence vient d'autoriser sans
condition le rachat des magazines prisma
par vivendi alors ça fait un faux écho
très loin de nous mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire en fait mais en fait ça serait
très près de nous donc les magazines du
groupe prisma ça va faire un des
premiers pôles magazines en france c'est
des centaines de morts et des dizaines
de
les aînés sont des centaines d'emplois
de journalistes a été racheté par
vivendi dont l'actionnaire principal est
vincent bolloré ça inquiète un peu quand
on voit le comportement de vincent
bolloré actionnaire dans les autres
médias dont il a le contrôle finalement
aujourd'hui à travers vivant dit qu'il
s'agisse de ses huit qu'il s'agisse de
canal+ ou à canal+ on a vu au cours des
derniers mois un certain nombre de
licenciements de deux journalistes pour
avoir eu le malheur de faire des sketchs
qui déplaisait à l'actionnaire ou de
soutenir
l'humoriste qui avait fait ses sketches
à canal+ ont également eu le recours à
la censure dès 2015 il ya eu la mise à
genoux de la chaîne d'information qui
était une télé pour la transformer en
ses new skies est à la fois alors c'est
mieux c'est vraiment le modèle
aujourd'hui de l'information low cost
plus de l'information qui devient de
l'information très politique très
politisée vous faites du clash tendance
extrême droite pour multiplier
l'audience au détriment justement de la
qualité du du débat démocratique ce cas
d intention politique derrière ces
propriétaires derrière ses actionnaires
dont on peut pas mettre tous les
actionnaires dans le même sac
derrière les intentions d'un certain
nombre d'entre eux c'est évident et
derrière celle de vincent bolloré si
vous étudiez l'évolution de la
programmation et de la ligne éditoriale
de ces mieux simplement en regardant à
la fois les invités et en regardant
aussi finalement de l'analyse de contenu
des thèmes qui sont traités en plateau
jour après jour on voit une évolution
très droitière voire extrême droitière
de la ligne de ses news et cette
évolution
elle a commencé après le rachat de la
chaîne par vincent bolloré
alors comment on lutte je vois que vous
proposez une loi de démocratisation de
l'information au concrètement ça veut
dire quoi c'est une proposition sérieuse
que vous faites par exemple au candidat
à la présidentielle oui ou candidat à la
présidentielle ou au gouvernement actuel
a ou législature on en a on en a discuté
avec benoît huppé avec la ministre
roselyne bachelot ce serait très bien si
c'était pour les candidats à la
présidentielle mais vous venez de
mentionner prisma ça va se jouer dans
les prochains mois et à la problématique
europe 1 paris match le jdd
ça va être dans les prochains mois m6 et
rtl sans doute avant la présidentielle
donc en fait ce serait bien que le
régulateur se saisisse du sujet avant la
fin de cette année nous qu'est ce qu'on
dit dans le livre on dit pour pouvoir
toucher des aides à la presse ou pour
que des radios et des télévisions est
taxé à des fréquences audiovisuelles
il faut que ces médias respectent un
certain nombre de règles et ces règles
visent à garantir l'indépendance du
travail journalistique
la première de ces règles c'est une
gouvernance démocratique des médias
on pense que les journalistes ce sont
les meilleurs garants de l'indépendance
de l'information et donc on propose que
dans tous les conseils d'administration
les organes de gouvernance des médias
d'information il y ait une moitié de
salariés dont deux tiers de journalistes
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on propose
que le directeur ou la directrice de la
rédaction soit validée à au moins 60 %
par les journalistes et pas des
pratiques qu'on a tiré de notre chapeau
c'est des pratiques qui existent dans
énormément de médias la validation du
choix du directeur de la rédaction on a
ça dans des médias aussi divers que le
monde les échos libération également et
puis 1,1 point fondamental puisque là on
évoquait prisma ou d'autres médias qui
font qu'ils vont changer de main
on propose la mise
place d'un droit d'agrément c'est quoi
un droit d'agrément un droit d'agrément
déjà c'est quelque chose qui est dans la
loi en france depuis 1944 mais qui a été
très mal écrit c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ont obtenus en 2019
les journalistes et les lecteurs du
monde ça permet aux à l'organe de
gouvernance d'un média qui inclut
typiquement au monde les journalistes
les lecteurs à la représentante salariés
de pouvoir se prononcer en cas d'entrée
d'un nouvel actionnaire
et si les journalistes les salariés
s'opposent à l'entrée de ce nouvel
actionnaire
ils sont ils ont un certain temps donc
trois mois en l'occurrence dans le cas
du monde pour proposer un actionnaire
alternatif et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est clé dans le cas de prisma
par exemple ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on
avait vu d'ailleurs dans le cas du
rachat de sciences et vie et des autres
titres de mondadori par reward c'est
qu'il y avait une opposition très forte
des salariés à ce rachat pourquoi parce
qu'ils voyaient les pratiques de ses
actionnaires dans les autres titres
qu'ils possèdent et précédemment il
voulait pas que ses pratiques s'applique
à et malheureusement ils n'ont pas eu
leur mot leur mot à dire mais pardonnez
moi est ce que ces pratiques n'arrive
pas aussi parce qu'il ya les réseaux
sociaux est ce qu'on arrive pas déjà
trop tard est-ce que les chaînes infos
ne sont pas embarqués aussi par des buzz
qui arrive sur les réseaux sociaux ou
même des informations qui arrivent
d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux et ils
sont un peu à la traîne donc ils se
dépêchent c'est pas le travail d'un
journaliste ça c'est vrai quand vous
étudiez aujourd'hui le contenu des
médias un regard traditionnel on voit l'
influence très forte qu'on les réseaux
sociaux sur la ligne éditoriale de ces
médias traditionnels sont armés ils sont
même lancée m al atrush huit heures
était le rédacteur en chef des médias
traditionnels
le problème c'est qu'on demande aux
médias d'information de nous informer
quand vous avez une fréquence
audiovisuelle vient le le fait d'être
sur l'a13 le fait d'être sur le canal le
numéro 15 numéro 16 simplement le fait
d'être sur le canal numéro 15 au numéro
20 simplement ce fait là on sait que ça
a une influence directe sur l'audience
que vous pouvez avoir et d'ailleurs
c'est de ça dont souffre aujourd'hui la
chaîne france info tvc qui en fait ils
sont très très mal numérotée sur un 7
sur la tnt
quand vous donnez à une chaîne numéro 15
le numéro 16 voulu donner un bien public
il y en a pas une infinité finalement de
canaux pour des chaînes voulu donner ce
bien public pourquoi on le donne est une
chaîne pourquoi il ya des conventions
avec le csa parce que
considère que c'est un bien rare et que
ce bien rare est nécessaire pour
l'information des citoyens donc ces
chaînes d'information ont une
responsabilité les réseaux sociaux c'est
un outil d'information certes un outil
de loisirs c'est un outil d'échangé un
outil de communication les chaînes
d'information elles doivent se détacher
finalement 2 ces buzz pour nous informer
c'est mal faire leur travail finalement
de s'accrocher à ces buzz là mais ce
qu'il faut quand même souligner c'est
que la plupart des journalistes des
salariés d'ailleurs qui travaillent pour
ces chaînes d'information ils ont pas du
tout envie eux de lire twitter tous les
matins pour décider l'après midi ce
qu'ils vont mettre dans leur journal ils
ont envie de faire de l'information de
qualité et c'est plutôt les actionnaires
qui en voulant réduire les coûts qui
licencient des journalistes vous faire
de l'argent et avoir des revenus
publicitaires mais réduire les coûts et
un moment faire de l'argent en ayant
plusieurs audiences donc plus de revenus
publicitaires pousse finalement vers
cette dégradation de la qualité de
l'information
il faut pas accuser des réseaux sociaux
il faut accuser le fait qu'on est en
train de courir derrière les réseaux
sociaux alors que c'est pas la bonne
manière de produire de l'information
vous ne travaillez pas seulement sur les
médias vous travaillez aussi sur les
questions de représentativité
démocratique
c'est l'objet des airs d'un livre que
vous avez publié en 2018 le prix de la
démocratie est là aussi
vous dites que l'argent privé emprisonne
la démocratie vous y fait deux
propositions fortes que les citoyens
s'impliquent dans le financement du
parti de leur choix ce qui permettrait
au parti de ne plus dépendre entièrement
des grosses fortunes et qu'un tiers de
l'assemblée nationale soit élu à la
proportionnelle avec au moins une moitié
d'employés et d'ouvriers
c'est assez révolutionnaire non oui ça
ferait beaucoup de bien au débat
démocratique sur la proposition du
financement des partis politiques il
faut savoir aujourd'hui vous avez deux
gros de grosse moitié de financement des
partis politiques vous avez un
financement direct des partis politiques
en fonction de leurs résultats aux
dernières élections législatives
et vous avez un financement qu'on oublie
souvent qu'il ya un financement indirect
qui passe par les réductions d'impôts
associés aux dons aux partis politiques
aujourd'hui en france si vous avez
beaucoup d'argent et vous donne et 7500
euros à un parti politique l'état c'est
vers l'ensemble des citoyens des 5000
euros à votre place et le coût net pour
vous n'est que 2 2500 euros si vous êtes
un français modestes que vous donnez ne
donnerait pas 7500 euros vous n'avez pas
les moyens de le faire mais vous donner
300 euros un parti politique
le coût pour vous veine de 300 euros
parce que comme vous n'êtes pas
imposable au titre de l'impôt sur le
revenu vous devez payer plein pot
donc on a ce système qui fait qu'on
marche complètement sur la tête on a mis
en place un système en france de
financement de la vie politique dans
lequel les plus port paix pour
satisfaire les préférences politiques
des plus riches
donc moi ce que je propose c'est de
réaliser sa de reprendre ces montants
d'argent public de les séparer en nombre
de citoyens de donner à chaque citoyen
ce que j'ai appelé un bon pour l'égalité
démocratique ça on pourrait l'appeler
différemment mais la même somme d'argent
public à chaque citoyen pour financer
mes mouvements politiques de son choix
ça c'est une première réforme nécessaire
pour recréer finalement de l'égalité
face aux financements la démocratie que
la démocratie ne soit plus ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire un euro une voix qu'on en
revienne aux fondamentaux une personne
une voix
et puis le deuxième fondamental
aujourd'hui à repenser dans notre débat
démocratique c'est le fait qu'on n'a pas
du tout des parlementaires à l'image des
à l'image des français aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale vous
le monde 2 % d'employés et d'ouvriers
les employés les ouvriers c'est toujours
50% aujourd'hui des citoyens français
donc ils sont ils sont pas du tout
représentés comment on a fait pour les
femmes pour les femmes on a changé la
loi et on avait adoré la parité et si on
n'avait pas instaurer la parité entre
les femmes et des hommes aujourd'hui on
déjà les femmes sont loin d'être
représenté la moitié
on en serait encore extrêmement loin
aujourd'hui bien pour ce que j'appelle
la parité sociale
il faut faire la même chose il faut
prendre le problème à bras le corps et
faire en sorte de changer des règles
pour garantir une parité entre la
représentation des catégories populaires
et la représentation des plus favorisés
vous êtes publiquement engagé à gauche
vous étiez dans l'équipe de campagne de
benoît hamon en 2017 et vous avez signé
récemment une tribune appelant à l'union
des gauches à l'union du camp écologiste
et sociale en 2022 je crois que c'était
dans libération vous y croyez vraiment
cette union des gauches
on peut pas faire autrement donc est ce
que j'y crois il faut être follement
optimiste pour y croire aujourd'hui
parce que c'est extrêmement mal engagée
c'est mal engagé par à cause des
citoyens les citoyens dans leur grande
majorité les citoyens qui votent à
gauche veulent cette union de la gauche
c'est mal engagée à cause de nos
politiques qui eût se refuse à la halle
à faire donc je pense qu'il faut une
pression citoyenne de plus en plus
fortes de plus en plus importante pour
obliger finalement tout le spectre de la
gauche à aller une primaire ensemble et
à n'avoir qu'un candidat unique vous
regardez sondage après sondage
les sondages les plus
négatif pour la gauche d'en donner la
gauche au premier tour à se rassembler
en faisant la somme aujourd'hui de tous
les candidats qui vont se présenter au
tour de 25 26% les sondages est plus
optimiste
autour de 32 33 % ce qui veut dire qu'en
fait la gauche a toutes les chances de
se qualifier pour le second tour avec un
candidat unique mais avec des
candidatures multiples vous avez 9 10 10
donc voilà vous avez trois candidats
peut-être que nora qui au final fera un
peu là pour cent en avant d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on a vu en 2010 cette
impasse que vous avez une coordination
des électeurs et qu'à un moment donné si
tout le monde doit benoît hamon chuter
dans les sondages et une rationalité
aller voter au premier tour
pour jean luc mélenchon va pas suivre
jean luc mélenchon si c'était lui qui
était bien sûr nié ou voiturier bien sur
wii - jade aussi oui moi je pense que
c'est extrêmement important que il y ait
une alternance politique en france
là les seules possibilités qu'on a c'est
soit la république en marche qui a
montré dans ses pratiques de politique
économique mais également de politique
sécuritaire de politique sur les
questions migratoires que c'était un
parti de droite
on a ce choix aujourd'hui entre la
droite ou l'extrême droite
je pense qu'il faut changer de politique
économique il faut changer de politique
sociale et pour ça la seule solution
c'est d'avoir une alternance avec la
gauche et donc ce le candidat de gauche
et 6 et jean luc mélenchon ça sera jean
luc mélenchon qui remportera la primaire
je serai la première à souhaiter pour
lui une gauche française qui est très
remué par le nouveau président américain
secoué dans le bon sens un et même très
agréablement surprise par les premières
mesures la nuit dernière devant le
congrès joe biden a détaillé sa
politique fiscale et sociale
complètement tourné vers les classes
moyennes ça va tanguer pour les
millionnaires et les multinationales
on écoute un instant et je vous fait
réagir après je n'imposerai aucune
augmentation d'impôts personnes gagnant
moins de 400 mille dollars
mais il est temps que les entreprises
américaines et que les 1 % d'américains
les plus riches commencent à payer leur
juste part
alors vous êtes économiste gili à kg
vous êtes donc de gauche on l'a bien
compris vous applaudissez d2
vous faites partie de ceux qui disent
gloire biden a écouté by donne depuis
qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir aux
etats-unis toutes les mesures qu'il a
mises en oeuvre vont dans le bon sens
d'ailleurs c'est amusant finalement de
faire le parallèle avec la primaire en
france si j'avais été citoyenne
étasunienne et que j'avais voté à la
primaire aux états unis je n'aurais pas
voté pour joe biden aurait plutôt voté
pour une elisabeth fois rien justement
parce que sur toutes les questions
économiques et elle voulait plus de
redistribution moins d'inégalités plus
de relance une taxation des sociétés
beaucoup plus forte etc mais byden ayant
gagné cette rumeur ensuite j'aurais voté
pour joe biden et là ce qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est de voir
que finalement aujourd'hui byden la
politique économique qu'il met en oeuvre
est beaucoup plus proche de l'ailé
gauche du parti démocrate que des
positions qu'ils poussaient lui-même
pendant sa campagne
donc ça montre finalement pensons on est
plus intelligent que de faire converger
finalement les différentes opinions ça
rend aussi beaucoup plus forte
et là c'est vrai qu'on ne peut
qu'applaudir les différentes mesures qui
ont été annoncées par par joe biden
ensuite il faut être prudent
il ya un peu de politique est un peu de
communication derrière tout ça parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui seront potentiellement
extrêmement difficile à faire passer
mais en tout cas ce qui dit tout ce
qu'il dit sur le fond de ce qu il y est
notamment par exemple toute la nouvelle
politique familiale qui sera financée en
partie par une taxation des surprofits
des dividendes et une taxation beaucoup
plus forte aussi haut niveau alors vous
dites les millionnaires et les
milliardaires n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
ils se tiennent très bien et si vous
regardez à la progression de leur
fortune au cours des dernières années ça
a plutôt bondy et y compris d'ailleurs
pendant le coup vite qu'ils étaient un
facteur d'aggravation des inégalités que
que ça ne sert que ça ralentit mais au
moins ils devront mettre la main à la
poche pour contribuer à cet effort et
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
positif donc
si la france et l'europe d'ailleurs de
ce point de vue leur pouvait éviter
d'être trop longtemps à la traîne des
états unis ce serait une excellente
chose à la traîne des états unis en un
mot est ce que c'est pas ben hayden qui
s'inspire plutôt du modèle social
européen
alors sur sur les questions par exemple
des crèches etc
du coup j'ai du congé maternité oui mais
ce qu'il est en train de dire sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés est le
le fait de remonter le taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés et puis de dire aux
entreprises étasuniennes vous allez vous
localiser en irlande pour payer moins
d'impôts très bien mais vous allez payer
la différence
aux etats unis c'est quelque chose que
l'europe aurait dû faire depuis des
années hélas ce qu'on voit plutôt c'est
que ce qui pousse et cette mesure en
europe se rapproche à l'exemple de dub
hayden pour essayer de la poussée
politiquement donc il ya des allers
retours de toute façon il faut toujours
apprendre les uns des autres et la bei
den est quand même en train de donner
quelques belles leçons de politique
merci julien kg d'avoir été notre avis
ce soit dans l'entretien je rappelle le
titre de votre ouvrage co écrit avec
benoît huvet l'information est un bien
public
refonder la propriété des médias merci
infiniment d'avoir été avec noël